Hunter is in LA hi hunter how are you
I'm doing great David how are you better
than I deserve what's up so I'm in a bit
of a dilemma here because as of last
month I was able to pay off all my
consumer debt with student loans and
personal loans and the last thing that I
have on my list is my vehicle I owe 16
thousand on it but my question is I plan
on buying a house
hopefully by December of this year and
I'm wondering if I pay off the card now
my credit will completely drop I think
I've heard from you before that it would
you know just completely erase after six
to eight months
no that's if you have zero obviously so
if you have zero accounts open of any
kind yes so do you you are you you don't
have any accounts open of any kind after
you pay the car off no sir
good pay the car off and then so go
ahead and pay it off and then hopefully
by December I'm assuming what my credit
is completely erased by then should it
really won't stick in the 600's it
doesn't it'll either stay where it is
it'll just disappear
that doesn't gradually erode okay that's
what I thought I thought it would just
slowly creak down and then by the time
this summer came I would kind of be you
know a blind try now you don't you don't
end up with a 500 credit score you mean
if you're sitting there at 700 near 700
700 and you have nothing on your account
eventually they can't calculate it
anymore it'll just disappear it might
take one notch down but I've never seen
any ones gradually erode so it could it
could it could drop a little and then
you know like if you if you pay off a
single credit card and you've got five
other accounts open you'll see an
incremental drop in the score based on
that okay sure but when you if you're
sitting there with a decent score and
you have one account left open and you
close that account and you have zero
activity on it
for six months to a year I've never seen
it gradually then I can't tell you
because they don't share the algorithm
with anybody obviously because people
would game it then but so we don't know
either all we've done is observed
what the Ramsey tribe has had happen
when they're doing this but I wouldn't
keep a car payment so that you can get a
credit score house in December No
so go ahead and get rid of it I would if
I were in your shoes I paid off today
hey thanks for the call man